When you're sleeping at night,
we camped.
We would do snow shoe like just deep into
the back. So we had, we would go into,
you had to do your cold weather training.
So getting your dry suits on and
swimming through the surf at nighttime.
Wonderful. Which is an ice cream
headache over and over and over again.
And as the ocean breaks over your head,
it's pretty bad. And the cold weather, uh,
immersion test is there where you have
to get into the water but just a pair of
shorts on for five minutes
and just then reward yourself.
So they get you to a point of hypothermia,
right to the edge. It's um, I think, uh,
as many things are in my old job,
there is a aspect of learning and there
is an aspect of tough it out and you
combine the two. So it,
it sucked. And there was,
there was a reason that
they wanted it to suck,
but they're also trying to teach a lesson.
Right?
But God forbid they just teach the lesson.
So they make you suffer to
ingrain it probably. Yeah.
So one day you wake up and on the board,
like a little white board that
has the list of gear you need.
It just says shorts running shoes. I'm
like, okay, this is February and Kodiak,
what are you talking about? They like
I said, I said, shorts, running shoes,
get out in the forward,
ICAN align van.
So we all get out there and they drive
to the beach where seawater is freezing
at the edge and they say, okay, go out.
You have to completely submerge
yourself neck deep water, five minutes.
And the timer starts,
timer starts when the last person
submerges their head. Oh God.
So you might be first, you might
be able to be all fired up and it,
you're just going to get seven and a
half minutes is what you're getting.
So you go and you sit
there and it's the coal,
it hurts for a minute
and then you're numb.
The worst thing about it
actually is rewarming.
It feels like you're just getting pin
pricked over and over and over again. Yes.
That's actually a Barklow.
Oh,
that is Barklow look at him standing up
there on that rock will Barklow has a
great rewarming drill that we actually
played on the podcast before for Sitka
where he uh,
takes their gear and jumps into a lake.
So that is the rather yeah.
And then re warms himself with basically
all sit cause gear and figures out how
to get your body back to what I thought
it was interesting that I'd never really
considered those.
That eating food actually ramps up your
body heat because you have to burn off
the calories,
your body starts processing.
The food actually is good for elevating
potty temperature, eating food,
especially if you can get hot food of
course. But just eating. So the drill,
the drill he was doing
actually had much more, uh,
I would say educational benefit
because they would make them,
they would take them there
with all of their gear,
their gearless would say whatever they
were wearing, plus bring your tent,
your sleeping bag and all your stuff
because we're going to put you into the
water and then you need to survive
your way out of it. So they would,
they would have to erect a tent.
They would have to get their sleeping
bag out all after being in the water for
five minutes,
which is exactly what a survival
situation is going to look like for us.
We went in there,
got back into the van,
and I sat in a hot tub and drank
beer for the rest of the day.
So I got the understanding of what it
feels like to be hypothermic and that just
see they have to push
their head underwater. Woo.
That guy right there is either screwing
everybody or was the first person to
complete it.
Um,
now Wim Hoff does so much of this
cold water submersion stuff and he,
he actually enjoys it and loves it.
You know?
Do you think that there's a way that
you could use like his methods and get
through that with less pain potentially,
even though you know,
all of the skills that I used in Kodiak,
I,
I did not ever use a single one of them.
Operationally,
I use his breathing method in the
Cryo tank. That makes sense. Therapy,
that makes sense. But that art does
Arctic conditions, I don't know,
at least in the modern theaters
of war were engaged in,
I don't know where the
applicability would be.
So it might be a little bit of a benefit
versus time expended to teach the guys
that stuff. You know,
because unless it's a,
we're talking like Korea probably
farther in the northern latitudes.
I mean it's, uh, like the
training was amazing. Like I said,
I didn't use a single bit of it.
Right. But if something, well,
it's also building mental
toughness and determination.
And that's why I said there's an aspect
of learning and there's an aspect of
just, this is going to suck.
Hey you guys, guess what?
You're going to do a 20 kilometer hike
into the back country and snow shoes.
There is no end state to this. There's no
target. You're going to do anything on.
You're just going to go out there and
you're going to do it and you're going to
survive out there and it's going to suck
for three days and then you're gonna
come back.
You just embrace this suck.
Or you learn how to pack your
backpack better, you know,
or you learn how to move better over that
terrain are you learn how to navigate
in that environment.
So there's always an essence of it,
but it just happens to be that there's
usually a pain component with it as well.
Yeah.
A lot of military training is like that.
There's an essence of a pain compliance
and then the actual learning technique
as well. Yeah, it's the learning
technique. I mean, it is really,
you're, you're learning a technique to
manage your mind under sucky conditions.
I mean, that is a
technique as well, right?
So I was actually having a conversation
with somebody about this recently. Uh,
I'm of the opinion that really the only
thing that I learned how to do when I
was a seal was to enhance my
ability to learn other things.
It's, you're selecting for people
and, and to get to that point,
you've got to maintain
control of your emotions,
whether you're in pain or you're
hot or you're cold. So there's that,
that essence of self control,
but then they require so many different
skill sets in so many different things
that the selection process is looking
for and then at the end of it,
teaching people how to become
better learners and then
you just refine that over
and over and over again over a career.
It's the ability to learn is probably
the biggest takeaway that I have from my
time in service.
I think that's the best thing you could
ever really learn is learning how to
learn. Like learning how to learn
correctly. Learning how to actual,
pay attention to what someone's teaching
you and absorb it and follow the steps
rather than fuck it up with your own ego
and your own insecurities or whatever
it is. It's going to trip you up.
If you can get good at something,
you know you can, you can apply that
to almost anything if you really,
yeah, and, and then they would pair
it with, we'll surround you by, okay,
we want to make you better at shooting.
So we are going to go find world champion,
pistol carving shooters.
Go apply your ability to learn with
them and we to do it for weeks.
Okay? Now you're going to specialize.
You're going to be appointment,
so you need to be able
to navigate and climb.
So we're going to send you out to Joshua
tree for two weeks with worldclass
climbers.
Go apply your ability to learn with them,
and then jumping and then diving,
and then tactics,
and then fill in the blank over a career.